tonight also overseas we get an inside
look on the effort to get afghans who
help the u.s during its mission in that
country to safety it's a race really
against the taliban which seeks to harm
or kill people viewed as collaborators
with the u.s national security
correspondent jennifer griffin shows us
tonight from the pentagon
sadi khalidi a kurdish iranian dissident
who protected americans in kabul had
been on the run with his family since
the u.s military left afghanistan he
applied for a special immigrant visa
last friday he received good news from
the state department congratulations
your chief of mission application was
approved for the afghan special
immigration visa program the only
problem is two weeks ago he was
assassinated he was a fine example of
someone who should have been
protected should have been saved his
wife and children are now on the run
after the taliban encircled their house
matt nelson of save our allies is one of
the private veterans groups helping
afghans escape his time ran out that's
just the
typical travesty that we're starting to
see
become more and more common every day
nelson a former marine left his job and
is continuing evacuations using private
donations he spoke from the middle east
where he is waiting for visas for 200
afghans including the parents of an
active duty u.s marine we have
brigadier generals we have female
journalists we've got
several
young hazara girls young war brides one
of those hazara women was visited by the
taliban this week when she got back to
her her house their taliban waiting for
and they they beat her severely broke
her nose and we moved her to a safe
place and put her in hiding since august
30th the state department has moved 500
people a week through the siv process
and has evacuated 900 americans and 2
000 afghans u.s officials say that
saudi's family who were included in his
visa application are likely eligible to
come to the u.s but first they have to
get out of afghanistan brett jennifer
griffin at the pentagon jennifer thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else